uh doing another review whilst i think
it's important that the public at this
moment of public outpouring feel that
they have an avenue for that
um and the government survey is one way
that people can come forward and say
what they think
but the issue of street harassment the
issue of sexual violence the issue of
domestic violence and all violence
against women and girls
we know what the problems are the home
secretary has known
for many years the minister has known
for many years
and it's it's just the reality is is
that last year 24
fewer rape convictions occurred domestic
homicide is at
an all-time high these we don't need a
survey
we can take action we can have policy
both through the domestic abuse bill
and also through the bill that is coming
before parliament on monday
we can change laws that mean that people
actually get good
sentences for rape that aren't sentenced
at all
that street harassment could be a crime
because it's not illegal to
harass women on the street currently we
don't need
a review we need action
how how far how much of the problem do
you think
is the police i mean as someone who was
there last night it did feel that the
police
slightly misread the move the mood um
you know they've also
advised people in the area women in the
area not to go out alone and there was a
lot of anger there last night about that
a lot of people there felt that it
encouraged
a victim-blaming culture do you think
the police are guilty of this
the mistake if we're talking about the
vigil specifically or that the police
generally need to be doing more in cases
of violence against women and girls
i'm afraid to say that that both are
true um
yesterday there were oh gosh so many
missed opportunities throughout the day
for the police to work with organizers
to create a completely safe vigil
so that people could go and have a
moment
of sorrow and a moment of resistance
against
what is the experience of pretty much
all women in the united kingdom and
around the world
and they miss the opportunity at every
every turn
until what we saw was
you know a five foot two tall woman
being pinned down with two
men on her back now what i have done
over many many years working with the
police
there are brilliant police officers in
the west midlands and across the country
who spend all their time trying to make
it
so that women feel confident to come
forward and yesterday
the police undermined that women already
feel like they won't be believed if they
come forward
and the images on the front of every
newspaper today
the police should apologize to the
coppers in my area who
desperately want to help victims of
violence against women and girls
because the police reputation
in this area needs improvement
before we show images of angry men on
the backs of women
do you think crested should go
oh gosh i don't i really don't want to
write the headlines so that the headline
out of this is
the labor party calls for crested
dictago before the vigil has even
happened
yesterday i was coming here to talk
about
what needs to change in this one moment
we have
it seems where the politics and the
views and wind is at our back as women
who have been fighting
for better for generations
and i'm here talking about cressida dick
the reality is is that i wish that i'd
had the heavy hand of the law when i'd
been sexually assaulted
i wish for every woman i've ever worked
with that the heavy hand of the law had
been there for them i wish for the woman
in my constituency this week who was
told no further action
on the rape that she'd brought forward i
wish the heavy hand of the police had
been there
for her but the reality is is if crested
dick stays or goes doesn't make women in
this country
more safe and that's what i want to talk
about we need to come together
to take action we don't need to just be
angry we need
action and the minister should be able
to lay out to us
exactly what they're going to do the
labor party has come up with
endless suggestions throughout the
domestic abuse bill something
you know 37 amendments we put down that
would make people safer
and on monday we will again be asking
the government
to look at things like misogyny as a
hate crime street harassment
as a crime and increasing the tariffs on
rape i'm afraid to say the bill that is
before us
on monday through in the explanatory
notes which i read on monday
there is more mentions of statues than
there is of women
10 years for
doing something to a statue what about
women
as you say let's go back to what we did
originally want you to come here
and talk about and it was international
women's day the the names of the 118
women that
you read out in the comments what struck
me
as a news presenter was that there was
no more than a handful of those names
that i recognized dead women don't make
the news these days do they
why do you think that is but also why do
you think the sarah everett case cut
through that and has gained
so much attention
the sarah rivera case unfortunately um
is is not vanishingly rare when we're
talking about women
killed women being killed happens every
three days in this country and like you
say
most people don't know the names of
those women which is why i read them out
and the sarah rivera case i think cuts
through
because it speaks to the every woman
experience of feeling
unafraid and because we heard the
reports
of what she had been doing prior to uh
going missing the phone call to the
boyfriend the walking
on a busy road it spoke to an experience
that every single woman in fact
the future queen of our country can even
say that it spoke to an experience that
she had felt
and that has ignited something in the
public
that has meant that sarah everard quite
rightly becomes
a lightning rod a pinnacle for us to get
behind
and that's it's not to say that she
matters more than those other women
who had died she's one of them and
it's on us to respect her family and
to respect all the women who feel
frightened to
take this time and make sure that we say
this is
enough is enough what are we going to do
tomorrow to make
sure that this doesn't happen again but
but being snatched on the street i mean
it's a dreadful situation what has
happened here but that isn't the real
risk
for most women is it that's it is very
much in the minority that this is how
uh women are attacked most of them are
attacked at home
at their partner's home or by their
partner the budget did allocate an extra
19 million pounds for domestic abuse
um in england and wales i mean
will that help will that make a
difference well the 19 million pound
allocated in the budget was largely uh
to go into perpetrator services which is
absolutely something that
we should be uh looking at only four
million of it was for
directly for victims and as victoria
atkins said this morning that's
2.3 million victims in the country so um
50 each from this year's budget
you know obviously we always need to do
more um
[Music]
where it should be going though you know
we both have two sons but both of us
we don't want our sons to grow up to be
the kind of men
that behave in this way to women so it
is the men that need to be educated so
shouldn't that be
where the funding goes when we look to
the future and how we can change society
i mean absolutely we should be uh
investing in perpetrators and
you know the the reality is is that the
government uh don't have a
currently have a strategy for
perpetrators of domestic abuse which
we've asked for repeatedly there isn't a
government strategy for how to deal with
perpetrators
let's maybe hope that this case uh has
made them change their minds on that i
very much hope so but you're absolutely
right that this is about education
and we made the the law a number of
years ago that compulsory
healthy sex and relationship education
had to be going on in
uh in schools that hasn't been started
to be rolled out properly because of the
pandemic which is totally understandable
but the government now have a
responsibility to be setting
standards of what that education has to
be and making sure
that they are resourcing it properly
because we've seen some terrible
examples for example
of some schools where they're teaching
girls that boys are the ones who should
instigate
sex so we've got to get this right in
education we've got to get this right in
health we've got to get this right in
welfare we've got to get this right in
housing
and we've got to get this right in
criminal justice because in every
single metric we are failing and in
every single metric
women are getting less safe year on year
if you look at the data for convictions
and you look at the number of women
coming forward
i mean it has been a terrible week a lot
of women will say and we look at the
sarah everard case and we look at what
happened last night
do you think as victoria atkins said
that that maybe this is a turning point
maybe
this is something that that a lot of
people have known was a problem within
society but it hasn't really
found a face found a voice and that now
we are at that point
real change may occur
look i really hope so somebody who has
been planning this for
for my entire career not just my entire
political career i really
i really really really hope that this is
the turning point
but i hope that about me too and not a
single piece of legislation has changed
in the united kingdom
that would protect people from being
sexually harassed at work that didn't
already exist
and every recommendation that has been
made to the government
on women's safety in the workplace since
the metoo movement which we all thought
was a moment
has been rejected by the government out
of hand
so when the minister says this is a
turning point when priti patel says this
is a turning point when boris johnson
says this is a turning point they have
an enormous majority in the house of
commons
they can turn their rhetoric into action
and i want that to be the thing i don't
want platitudes i don't want nice words
i don't want clapping
i don't even want candles i want action
to change this because i am tired of
reading out so many people's names